My name is Jocelyn.
I am a member of the Voorhees
Toastmaster Club, District 38,
and I am the World
Champion of Public Speaking for 2023.
Can you tell me every emotion
that is going through your body right now?
It's just surreal.
You ever have a wave of just,
"I can't believe this is happening?"
It's almost an out of body kind of vibe,
but it's just... I'm excited,
I'm ecstatic, I am speechless.
And it's just—
amazing.
What went through your mind when you heard
your name called as World Champion?
First thing: What?
What? Wait... what? Me?
Wait, me, me, just. Me?
I think that was the first thing and
still feel like it's going on right now.
Can this be me?
But I worked hard
and it was a labor of love.
So I'm just grateful. Just grateful.
Who helped get you to where you were?
It was definitely
family, friends, fellow Toastmasters,
non-Toastmasters,
and just different audiences
that I was bringing the speech to.
I just wanted to be relatable to them
and everyone when I was giving that speech
because I practiced with them,
I spent time with them
and just pooled and cultivated this thing.
And that's who I thought of.
And just also having fun
and remembering that day
and remembering what brought me there,
and that that speech was my story.